so let me
very briefly recap what we
uh discussed last time
so we started off with thinking about
choices under risk how do people think
about uh
economic behavior when things are
uncertain when there's risk involved
i sort of discussed and showed you sort
of the main workers model
that economists use to study risk that's
sort of expected utility
that is a very commonly extremely useful
model for many situations so it's like
very
widely used if you ask like 100
economists randomly
which model explains choices and the
risks the majority will surely tell you
expected utilities what you should use
it explains a wide range of phenomena in
very useful ways you can think about
lots of different things
you can for example think about
investment behavior finance
when you think about what should you
invest in
if things become more risky if acids
are are more volatile you need to have a
higher
return for that or need to be offered a
higher return to invest in those assets
and so on and so forth
there's lots of useful applications in
finance using expected utility
you can think of a range of different
issues you can think about for example
criminal behavior
about sort of the risks of getting
caught what happens when the risk of cod
goes up people engage in less crime and
so on and so forth
there's lots of different behaviors that
we can think about and explain using
expected utility so what i i do want you
to sort of take away like
the expected utility model is a very
useful model for various applications
what we're trying to do is trying to
understand are there some applications
for which perhaps
uh the expected utility model
has some limitation perhaps because of
its simplicity or parsimony because
there's only one parameter in there
can we sort of alter that in some ways
and try to make it
uh more realistic in in some situations
so the key parameter of interest when
you try to sort of estimate this model
trying to sort of match the data in some
ways
the parameter that you need to estimate
here is you need to sort of assume some
functional form
this is what i i did last time i can
show you this
stream this year so one a very commonly
a functional form is the cra
um a utility function that's very widely
used in a lot of
range of settings uh the feature of that
is a it has like constant relative
versus conversion
uh and that has a bunch of like useful
properties for estimating things or
making predictions
so what you then need to do is if you
try to sort of estimate somebody's risk
preferences how do people
uh behave under risk what you need to do
then is sort of assume some functional
form
for example the cra utility function and
then the question is kind of like how do
we estimate
gamma the risk conversion parameter
that's the key parameter in this model
now how do you do that um
i showed you some different choices that
you get essentially revealed preference
economists believe in reward preference
i give you some choices that involve
risk
and depending what you choose that
reveals what your gamma is
so you can do like uh small scale
gambles which just looks like small
choices between different options some
entail moral risks and others
and then you can essentially just sort
of uh estimate using those choices
or people's certainty equivalent for
such choices
uh what's people's gamma is now what we
found is that when you have small spare
gambles people look
or appear very risk-averse they're like
often
decline gambles with a positive expected
value which makes them appear quite
risk-averse once you sort of
estimate this parameter gamma gamma
looks like gamma is
above 10 above 20 above 30 really really
high
now at the same time you can look at
large scale risks and there when you
look at large scale choices
um when you sort of think about like
what's a reasonable gamma people
actually
only appear moderately risk-averse it
doesn't look like the particular
risk-averse
uh we sort of think for those
large-scale choices i mean look at
finance or housing or other applications
but people have estimated such models
you get like gammas that are between
zero and two and uh
roughly now um what that then applies is
if you gamma is between zero and two
that means essentially
uh for small scale gambles uh you should
be essentially wrist neutral you should
not care about really small risks that
are about a dollar or two um
so that sort of poses a problem because
now we have like sort of two
contradicting answers we have like for
small scale
uh risk it looks like people are really
risk-aversed for large-scale gambles it
looks like people are not so risk-averse
now we only have like one parameter is
this gamma which is coming from the
concavity of the utility function
uh and when we only have one parameter
and sort of two contradicting sort of
pieces of evidence we can't sort of
match both
right because if you wedge match 101
then essentially you can't match the
other and um
vice versa now uh i showed you a little
bit um
matthew raven's uh what he calls the
calibration theorem which is essentially
sort of calibrating showing
in a fairly compelling way that um in
fact
uh uh you can formally show it's not
about sort of assumptions of a specific
utility function or the like
for re very sort of minimal assumptions
which is just the utility function is
weekly
uh uh concave um you can essentially
show that like declining small-scale
gambles
uh with high with positive expected
value
implies that people are uh
uh uh make absurd choices when the when
the gambles become larger
uh the recitation will discuss this a
bit more and more detail and sort of
going walking you exactly uh and and
somewhat
slower speed through through this
specific example now then
uh what we started then last time was
thinking about uh insurance choices
this is a very nice paper by uh justin
sidner
and one very nice feature of this paper
is that it involves real world choices
so it's not like some lab experiments
with
some experiments of course some people
care a lot about undergrads
some people might say well what are
these undergrads choosing anyway what
does this have to do with viewable
choices
i think undergrads are great um uh but
you know uh
one might wonder like if you recruit
people into some experiments
and you see some choices like what are
these choices really real like do we
really find
that these choices are predictive of
real world behaviors so one answer to
that is well let's find some data from
the real world let's look at like real
choices that people have made
in real world setting and this is
exactly what sydner does
so what he does is he has this data set
of large homage
from a large home insurance provider
this is sort of 50 000 standard policies
that are sort of like
representative of what people choose um
overall
and the key uh outcome of interest uh
in a study is like people's deductible
choices what's a deductible again these
are expenses paid out of pocket before
the insurer
uh pays any expenses so you have like a
deductible of 500
you have a damage of like uh uh uh 200
you have to pay it all yourself if you
have a damage of a thousand dollars you
pay the 500
and then the insurer pays the rest right
and so
what he has is he has choices of a menu
of four deductibles for each
customer um or client
so you can see both people's choice sets
and you can see people's preferred
options and that allows them to sort of
say well if you preferred
if you have four options you picked one
of them that means you preferred that
one over the all three others
so we can sort of essentially uh put
some bounds on people's um risk aversion
and so we looked at this already this is
kind of what this referee looks like
um there's different deductibles which
essentially again like how much the
insurance pays before
um how much you have to pay yourself in
case of a damage until the insurance
payments kick in
you have the premium which is like how
much for sure do you have to pay every
year
and then there's uh the the premium
relative to the thousand dollar policy
how much more expensive is it
that's in the third column how much more
expensive is it to choose a lower
deductible
relative to the thousand dollar premium
and then we have people's choices which
is uh in this case i guess uh
policyholder one shows a deductible of
250.
uh it was a premium of
was 661.157 dollars more expensive than
the thousand dollar
um uh uh deductible option
okay and as for each policy make for
each policy holder
uh the company was in fact sort of
providing individual
uh prices so essentially they're looking
at what is people's
where do they live what's the housing
value and so on and so forth
sydner knows all of that so he knows
like the full set of options that people
had available and their actual choices
and the options available vary by person
okay
now um uh how do we learn now about risk
aversion well so
the losses to the customers are capped
by the deductible right so if any loss
you have from the
from any damage that you get the losses
are uh
only up to the deductible so if you have
a deductible of 500
the most you can lose is or have to pay
in any case and
if any loss occurs is 500 right so
choosing a lower deductible then what it
does it amounts to essentially
reducing that loss in case you have a
damage so if you have a deductible of
500
uh and decide to instead choose a
deductible of 250
that means essentially in case there's a
damage in case um you have to pay
something
you don't have to pay 500 you have to
only pay 250.
uh but of course if you lower your
deductible the price of your
uh your insurance goes up the premium
goes up
and the premium you have to pay for sure
okay so the way you can think about this
then it's like
if you choose a lower deductible for
sure you have to pay more money
but you know in case there's some damage
you you with some probability
uh that happens uh if you have some
claims you have to like pay
less because your deductible is now
lower okay
so now what info do we actually need we
need the available deductibles like
essentially what are the deductibles for
each choice
we need the premium for each option we
need to claim probabilities and people's
wealth levels
right because you have a utility
function where there's wealth in there
i'll talk about this in one second
any questions so far
okay so now uh one important feature and
this i think was asked like last time
about like
well what about the claim rates well if
the claim rates are really high or
people think the claim rates are really
high
in some since then having very low
deductibles makes a lot of sense because
then you know
and very often it happens that you have
to pay then you know you might actually
not have a
you it makes lots of sense to have like
um no deductibles but it turns out
claims rate actually very
low so you can see um overall
and this is like the full sample this is
everybody people's claim rates is 4.2
percent these are yearly claim rates
this is like
out of 100 customers 4.2 per year uh
actually
claim any damage um and then it that
varies a little bit by the
also by choice of deductible so there's
the people who chose who
happened to choose in the end like a
thousand dollars five hundred dollars
250
and a hundred dollars but for each of
them essentially the claim rate is below
uh five percent so it's very low
okay the second factor from his data is
that
reducing the deductible is very
expensive so for example here's um
uh uh this is the full sample again on
average
purchasing the insurance um where the
deductible of a thousand dollar cost 615
uh
dollars we can't say very much about
that because about that choice because
who knows how much the actual damages
are and so on in some sense that's sort
of irrelevant for us what that number is
what we're interested in is like what
are the differences across the different
deductibles
how much do you have to pay to lower
your deductible to like 500
250 and so on now what you see here is
like
on average reducing the deductible from
a thousand dollars to 500
which is sort of what this column shows
that's um shown in red
costs uh 900 sorry 99 dollars and 91
cents
you know so that's is that a if you
choose then like 500
is this a risk-averse choice or not how
do we think about that
suppose your claim rate is like say five
percent
yes well i think it would be a
risk-averse
decision because you're paying 100
dollars more
and your deductible has gone down by
five hundred dollars so claim rate
for a back of the envelope calculation
would need to be about
exactly so what you're saying is um
you're reducing the deductible from a
thousand dollars to five hundred dollars
uh now if you think that happens with a
five percent chance on average you're
going to get back uh
you're gonna reduce your payments by
twenty five dollars
right so it's five percent times um a
hundred dollars
uh uh 500 which is uh 25
uh but people are willing to pay about a
hundred dollars for that
so for sure they're paying a hundred
dollars uh
and the benefit that they get is with
five percent chance at least the average
customer
with five percent chance uh they're
gonna pay uh 500
um less in case there's some damage that
looks already
pretty risk-averse right because as one
since surely you're not risk neutral
because then you would not do that you
would choose the thousand dollars
uh it looks fairly risquers now
if you go down then if you go to like
from 250 to
200 there's an additional 133 dollars
and 22 cents
so that's to say reducing your
deductible by another 150 dollars from
250 to 100
makes you for sure you have to pay 133
dollars and now if your chance is like 5
of getting like essentially a damage
that is for a 5
chance of like saving 150 people are
willing to pay
133 dollars for sure okay
so now if you try to calibrate this what
we already know from this exact simple
example is that people look extremely
risk-averse
okay so that's kind of like the exercise
that that
[Music]
that sidner is doing just saying like
look let's take these choices very
seriously let's look at people i've done
in real world situations these are
repeat customers you
have done this for a long time and so on
what are people choosing
and if we sort of assume expected
utility
uh what would neet people's gamma need
to look like to be able to explain uh
this data if we can do this customer
this is like the average
rates we can do this sort of customer um
by customer
now what he then finds is people choose
the majority of people
choose small deductibles lots of people
choose um
uh 250 500 very few people choose a
thousand dollars
even among people and this is on the
x-axis who have been at the company for
15 plus years right you would say like
the first time you do this maybe you
don't understand your claim rate you
don't understand what's going on or
whatever
but there's people who have been at this
company for 15 years uh you know they
should kind of know
at some point that claim rates are
pretty low um uh
at least on average um uh and so like if
you have 15 years
at this company it's hard to believe
that you still think that um
uh your claim rate is say above 10 or
the like since it just hasn't happened
um very often
okay um now
how do we think about people choosing a
deductible again what you need is like
the following parameter you need to have
a yearly the yearly premiums you need to
have the deductible d
uh you're assuming sort of no other risk
to lifetime wealth which is a bit of a
distraction but essentially
you can't diversify risk and so on and
so forth um
you could also you can assume there's at
most one risk per year this is again
sort of simplification it doesn't really
matter very much with probability um
pi and then uh for for for now at least
we
assume accurate subjective beliefs about
the likelihood of a loss
now then what is then the indirect
utility function of wealth what does
sort of utility function look like
depending on these parameters
uh can somebody explain this what what
i'm showing here what is this
equation yes
your wealth if something happens and
then after the probability pi and then
the one minus pi is
uh your utility of your wealth is
nothing that happens so all you need is
exactly so for sure so with one
probability one minus pi nothing happens
you have your wealth w that you had
before um you have to pay the premium
for sure so in that case you also have
to pay the premium so you're going to
end up with like w
minus p the premium and then with
probability pi
you also have to pay the premium which
is you know a w minus p but also you
have to pay the deductible because some
damage uh
occurred right and then sort of your
indirect tool your expected utility
uh for that year is essentially then uh
the weighted average of these things and
uh
pi is essentially the the weight on that
which is the uh
subjective or in this case assume the
actual probability of a damage occurring
now i sort of said you know indirect
utility function
uh uh utility of wealth function what is
that or what's a what's an indirect
utility function and b
why is there wealth in it and not
consumption as like you know usually we
think people eat stuff and
uh uh you know there should be like
consumption in here
why do we have wealth in here what what
is this
yes i think they might be like assuming
uh
that for each level of when you are
optimizing your conception
and it's very stable
exactly and what what what is the
indirect utility function
exactly so usually you think like what
you do is you are uh if you
go back to like 1401 uh notes or what
was done in the first i think recitation
usually what you do is you uh maximize
consumption
uh with several goods or one goods or
whatever over time
uh and usually there's a budget
constraint and wealth is usually in your
budget constraint right you can only
consume
as much as how much money you have could
be like your income or your wealth
if it's over your lifetime now when you
do that and maximize it then you end up
at an optimum what you can then do is
like essentially express
the optimum uh assuming that you have
chosen optimally your consumption as
we're saying you already chose whether
you wanted apples or bananas or whatever
we assume that you optimize i can then
essentially just say assuming that
you're optimizing
what is your optimized utility for
different levels of wealth
and usually it's a function of wealth
and prices right and that's what the
uh the um the indirect utility function
is
uh we can very briefly also go over that
in in recitation
but if you go back to your um uh uh 1401
uh or other notes
you will see essentially that uh it's
the outcome of a maximization problem
usually it's like for two goods or
whatever like it's it's like
income in this case it's wealth because
it's like over um
uh uh yeah it's wealth but it could be
available income as well if you want it
now um
what is the person then going to do is
like each contract has
gives you a a an expected utility in
terms of like how much do you expect
your utility to be if you choose that
specific contract and now the
maximization problem is now you choose
the contract j
that maximizes the expected utility or
the expected indirect utility
as a function of these parameters okay
any questions on this so essentially for
each contract we can write down what's
the indirect utility uh
a function uh it depends on people's
wealth so we have to make some
assumption of how wealthy people are
and it depends on these other parameters
depends on the premium it depends on the
deductible and it depends on the
subjective probability of
a claim occurring in that year we assume
that there's only one claim per year
okay so now um what we can do is then we
can back out the implied
risk aversion from people's choices um
uh and in fact what we can do is we can
get upper and lower bounds on people's
risk aversion from what they have chosen
let me sort of give you an example
for that suppose a person chooses a a
hundred dollars
uh deductible what does this mean well
this means essentially that
he he or she preferred the hundred
dollars deductibles over all the other
deductibles that um
were available right so there's
essentially if you choose the 100
you get three inequalities you get like
100 deductibles better than the 250
deductible 100 is better than 500
tallest deductible
and 100 is better than a thousand
dollars uh deductibles
now this gives us a bound on people's
risk conversion is it the lower and
upper bound
or and why
yes i think it's a lower bound because
100 premium is like
the lowest you can go in a lower premium
bodies sorry a lower deductible implies
more risk aversion
so right exactly sort of like a corner
solution so like what if the person who
chooses 100
that's the person that i just showed you
previously this is this example that i
showed you here
um where is it
this is a person who looks extremely
risk-averse right this
person essentially is saying like i'm
choosing the lowest possible deductible
i'm for sure paying quite a bit of money
compared to all these other options
four or five percent chance of not
having um uh
uh a damage so this person will look
very risk-averse
uh it's the lowest possible option so
maybe the person if there had been like
a fifty dollars or
a zero dollars option would have even
chosen that option we don't know because
that's not available
but so what you can then do is however
you can just write down these
inequalities and so if you choose the
100
deductible compared to the 250
deductible it will be the case that
if you sort of solve for gamma this
gives you a lower bound for
or gamma so that's what does that mean
we know gamma is at least
as high as as you know uh uh the
solution of this inequality will tell us
but in fact uh their gamma could be even
higher we just don't know it because we
don't have additional um
choices now if you choose the a thousand
dollars deductible on the
on the other hand you'll get like an
upper bound uh uh and the the reason is
exactly exactly the same essentially if
you choose the thousand dollar
deductible that's like the riskiest
option you can choose
right because you can essentially you're
choosing essentially something you you
will
not choose not to reduce your risk in
any way so you're not willing to pay to
do that
it's kind of like declining essentially
or accepting a gamble and not choosing
to save
options but we don't know whether this
person would have chosen like
a thousand dollars in one deductible or
two thousand dollars or five thousand
dollars what deductibles would have been
chosen because there's no other
higher options of deductibles so now um
and then in between we have essentially
lower and upper bounds because
essentially we know that if you choose
500
we know that you didn't choose a
thousand and we know also that you
didn't choose 250
so your gamma must be in between those
options whatsoever is implied by those
two
options um there's a
previous problem set that we posted that
sort of walks you through that
uh we'll also go through that um uh and
recitation sort of to
to go through the mechanics of that
any questions on this
yes
but that's just uh you you i think the
so
that's not a problem because it's it's
it just sort of flipped
uh so you have the gamma uh that's why
you have the gamma in the in the
denominator as well
so you get a problem if your gamma is
one because in dividing by one then
usually people use a
log utility for that
and not yeah to choose extreme
positions and not only
conversion yes that's a great question
so
i'll get to this in a second so what i
have done
right now and this is the typical way
like economists think about these things
is sort of say
let's take a model very seriously here's
the model that i'm using to try to
explain people's choices
um and now i'm essentially assuming
everything else away i'm choosing i'm
essentially assuming that the person
optimizes
there's no mistakes there's no framing
of facts there's no other stuff going on
and no liquidity constraints and so on
and now i'm taking this very seriously
i'm estimating gamma
now the typical and this is in section
four of the paper in fact
the typical thing then people that
happens is other people are gonna say
like well what about like
uh people don't understand what they're
doing what about people misperceiving
the risk what about people
um framing effects in terms of like the
way you present um
the choices people like to not choose
extremes but like to choose in the
middle
uh can that explain um uh the results
um there are some concerns about like
that i think
one thing that your explanation for
example would be able for perhaps to
explain is people choosing 500
over like a thousand it's hard for you
for the framing effects to explain why
people are choosing 250.
right so if you look at this figure in
particular the people who
um are in the company for 15 years
lots of people choose uh deductibles of
250.
it's a little bit harder to explain with
framing effects why wouldn't you
choose like 500 as opposed to 250
uh so the signal argues that's really
not what's going on i think at the end
of the day
probably it's the case that people do
not want these extremes and to some
degree i think
some of what's going on is perhaps at
least contributed by some form of
framing effect so maybe marketing you
know
people sell the insurance uh choices
really want people
like they get more uh paid presumably if
they
they sell essentially these little
deductibles because that's how the
company makes a lot of money
uh what citnar says there is like well
it's actually hard to sell people on
stuff that they don't like
it seems like people really seem to want
these things and maybe some of that is
sort of sales pressure but probably not
everything
so i think some of this going on it's a
little bit hard to to rule out
all of those things uh but if you read
the paper
it's reasonable and since what i'm going
to show you next is like the implied
gamma is
like so large that even if you sort of
says okay half of this effect is driven
by other things
you would get still like really absurdly
large um estimates of risk
aversion but that's a great question yes
um well to some degree in some sense i
think that the way they sort of so sorry
the question was like is the company
deliberately giving people choices that
leads them to choose low deductibles and
this is therefore do we sort of
overestimate people's gamma to some
degree yes but it's not like just we
have you know
low deductibles available there's a
thousand dollar option available
i think there's maybe what you're
alluding to is like there's some sales
pressure
and so on going on that might well be
true and people sort of might
you know emphasize risk and make it
particularly salient and make customers
nervous and say like look these floods
and so on are
going on and really low deductibles are
good i think to some degree that's
true but you have to be pretty
compelling in
in any reasoning one other comment is
like
there's lots of other examples of people
choosing low deductibles and sort of
extended warranties and so on and lots
of cases
for example if you look at like iphones
or ipads and so on and so forth
laptops etc lots of apple in particular
but other companies try to
sell extended warranties that are if you
actually did this exact same
calculation are not worth engaging in
or that reveal essentially extreme risk
aversion among customers
um i myself um looking at this kind of
research there's lots of research sort
of argues that people shouldn't choose
extended warranties
of course then i i
uh when i bought a laptop uh uh the last
time i was like of course i don't need
extended warranties and then of course
uh uh soon after the laptop um you know
uh uh uh brokens on and i didn't have
warranty and so on
so of course in specific examples that
may happen but on average
it's it's it's not a good idea to to do
okay so now um what does the signal find
so now here
in this table you can see the implied
estimates of gamma remember what we said
is what we think is a reasonable gamma
is somewhere between 0 and 2 for large
scale choices
he has different types of assumptions he
has like lower bounds and upper bounds
of
gammas and what essentially you see is
the gammas are like
depending what the assumptions are in
the hundreds or in the thousands
it depends a little bit what people's
wealth is so essentially depending on
how much you assume people so what the
data that he does not have is
what is people's wealth actually uh like
how much money do people actually have
so you make some reasonable assumptions
for saying like look these are people
whose houses are like two hundred
thousand three hundred thousand four
hundred dollars worth
so presumably and we know from other
data sets like how much roughly how much
money people have available
so then depending on essentially what
utility function you assume
he is he is mostly using like cra
utility uh about like then as
a wealth of like um um uh
a a a million dollars you can look at
like 100 000
50 000 5 000 and so on you can also use
cara utility which is constant absolute
risk aversion and so on
and essentially what you have to assume
is like extremely low levels of wealth
so about something like five thousand
dollars
to get into like sort of single digits
or uh double digits of of gamma
it's extremely hard to sort of uh get
estimates that are
reasonable in the sense of like that we
think are actually reasonable on
parameters
of gamma any questions on this
okay so now you know why do people
choose those small deductibles and this
is what
what you were saying before so so one um
uh neoclassical explanation would be
well they must be really really risk
versus the gamma must be really high
uh there you might sort of say well uh
uh you know we know already that gamma
shouldn't be that high from some other
choices so that's sort of hard to
reconcile
is there a question no
um second you could say well there's
really high objective probabilities of
claims we know that the objective
probability is only four or five percent
uh you'd have to sort of have
probabilities of claims that are like 20
30 40 to be able to match these data
now it could be that people have risk
misperception it could be that people
really think you know the probability is
actually 20 when it's
at the end only five or four now what's
sort of inconsistent with that is that
like
repeat customers people have been at the
company for 10 15
20 years are making very similar choices
in some sense you know you
it's hard to reconcile that everybody is
misperceiving this risk uh
year after year after year and spending
lots of money
um there's some questions on is it
borrowing constraint is it like people
just don't have enough money um
uh are they worried about um about
having to pay um
uh uh these deductibles that also seems
quite unlikely because in fact the
deductibles are not particularly it's
not like about we talk not talking about
like five thousand dollars
people could sort of if they really face
these poor concerns they could save and
so on
so uh uh sidner also argued that that's
not going on
there's some questions about marketing
social pressure and so on which is like
of course the company has very much like
incentives to sell people these kinds of
deductibles
um i think some of that is probably
going on and it's hard to rule out
entirely
again like it's hard to actually sell
people's stuff that they don't really
want to
um so you know there must be lots of
social pressure to to to in fact do that
menu effects already talked about a
little bit uh uh
there you know we think that um maybe
menu effects can explain why people
choose 250 sorry 500 or like the
interior choices where they don't choose
a thousand
it's hard to explain with menu effects
why people choose 250 over
um 500. now so then sidner's preferred
explanation is then reference dependent
preferences and lots of version which
we're going to talk about um
next yes is there any data on whether
like the probability of the claim is
correlated with
which menu options like
yes there is um so you have a uh
you have it here so uh it's sort of
weakly correlated in a sense like if you
choose uh
or weekly negatively correlated so the
people who choose
a thousand dollars have uh uh 2.5
um uh claim rates and uh
the the uh you know the hundred dollars
at 4.7
so that's kind of not quite explaining
things um either yeah
i think they use a plus-size regression
to control for the fact that
those with lower deductibles may play in
multiple times
i see yes uh great yes
okay um so so what do we learn from this
i think sort of
i think this is very much sort of
confirming some of the lab evidence data
on like relatively small scale gambles
these are not like
small small-scale gamblers of like a
dollar two or five or ten
these are about like you know several
hundreds of dollars but they're not
about like
you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars so you know these are relatively
small relative to like people's lifetime
wealth
and what we see for those kinds of
choices is really looks like people are
people are very um appear to be very
very um
risk averse this is what i was saying
already previously
when looking at sort of reasonably small
scale choices and i count sort of the
sidner evidence has reasonably small
scale choices because it's not about
like hundreds of thousands of dollars
you essentially see that people um such
choices imply sort of as way you see
people seem very risk-averse these
choices
imply enormous risk aversion for large
scale risks
um but you know people are not avoiding
all sorts of large scale risks that
people take on lots of large scale risks
so in some sense that can't be true in
some ways
um we also find that individuals are
moderately risk-averse for a large scale
risk people are taking on some risk as i
said
now if you sort of take that seriously
and say well people might not be
that risk-averse that is a in turn
implies that people are nearly
risk neutral they should be nearly risk
neutral for
small-scale risk so it can't be that
both of these things are true at the
same time
now um in fact there's a much older
paper
and that's a very famous and seminal
paper um by kahneman and chersky
kahneman got the nobel prize um in fact
for
for this work on similar uh work uh
importantly i'm uh or
kahneman is a psychologist and they were
doing psychology experiments and it just
turned out that these ecology psychology
experiments
were extremely influential in uh
affecting how economists think about
risk and risk perspective risk
preferences in particular sort of
reference dependent uh preferences and
so
what kahneman and firsky were doing at
the time way before a lot of this other
literature that i just showed you
a they showed even more sort of evidence
against the expected utility model
um but perhaps more importantly they
also proposed an alternative model and
saying like look
here's some choices that we think are
not really making uh are like hard to
explain and hard to rationalize using
expected utility
now here's a different model that can
explain things
[Music]
perhaps better in some situations um
so what did kana manchester actually do
the experiments are actually extremely
simple in various ways they're very
clever and very clean
um but actually very simple and so what
do these experiments look like
these are survey responses like
essentially they just ask people about
what would you do in different
situations
this is not what economists were doing
at the time economists at the time were
like saying like
revealed preferences are important i
need like to make you make you to do
actual choices
uh whatever you say in surveys doesn't
matter because you know who knows what
you have but whether you actually mean
what you say
it turns out that the survey responses
are actual these are hypothetical stakes
but it turns out that if you do this
with actual stakes you find very similar
results um and the uh experiments were
as follows there were things like
questions like which of the following
would you prefer kind of like i showed
you in the first
class at the end um uh the the survey
that you did
uh would you prefer option a which is a
50 of uh winning a thousand dollars or
50
chance of winning nothing versus option
b is like 450
um for sure and so the series of these
types of questions
now
one of the things that then they showed
is or one key prediction of expected
utility is that
as i said before people only care about
final outcomes
uh and their associated probabilities um
economy and of course you show a bunch
of different striking uh contradictions
of that
i want you to focus on the first row
problem three and problem three prime
and look at that and sort of tell me
what of that
example is contradicting expected
utility
if you can see this
so let me just read this for you if it's
hard to see but like think of us for a
second
problem three says um uh uh
would you uh prefer uh an 80
chance of four thousand dollars over uh
three thousand dollars for sure
what do you see below then these are
always a hundred people you see the
number of people
who preferred one option over the other
so 80 people
um prefer the 3 000 option uh 20 people
said i'd rather have the 80
chance of uh four thousand dollars
that's problem three
problem three prime is um about what
they call negative prospects
uh would you prefer um uh an 80 chance
of losing four thousand dollars
or for sure losing uh three thousand
dollars
okay and there you see uh 92 percent
uh uh uh choose the first option
and uh eighty percent choose a three
thousand dollars loss
uh for sure
let's start with this the the the left
example what did we learn from the left
example
are people risk averse risk neutral risk
loving or what do we learn from that
risk averse and why is that um if you
calculate the expected
monetary value um
right so we said before somebody's risk
neutral if uh the person is indifferent
between two options when they have the
same expected monetary value
right and so in this case an eighty
percent chance of four thousand dollars
three thousand 200
in expectation right and um but there's
a bunch of people who say i'd rather get
the 3 000
which is less than 3 200 for sure
which means essentially they take a
shore like an option that's for sure
um they get they prefer that over the
uncertainty of getting zero versus four
thousand which on average gets them more
3200 expected utility would say if you
choose that option
it must be that you are risk-averse
okay now uh not everybody seems
risk-averse
uh there's 80 people out of 100 uh
choose that or 80
i think it's 80 uh choose that um and
the remaining ones
um choose the other option this person
uh the other people could be
we don't know much about they're not
very risk-averse but they could be also
risk-averse just like it wasn't revealed
in their choice
there okay so from the left side we say
we know at least
80 people or 80 of the the sample is
risk-averse
now let's look at the right side what do
you see on the right side
but they prefer the minus
right so now it looks like so if you
look at the left option
uh it's minus 3200 so the left option
has
more risk and it also has a lower
expected monetary value as you said at
the expected monetary value it's just a
flipped
of the problem three it's minus three
thousand two hundred
um and the other one is minus three
thousand so if your universe neutral
surely you would choose the minus three
thousand if you instead you choose at
minus three thousand two hundred
well it must be that you really
appreciate that there's additional risk
there
so it looks like you're risk-loving
okay and now we find here that ninety
percent and ninety-two percent of the
sample choose
the first option but at the same time
with the same people when they're
uh uh you know offered um or
given the choice been problem three
eighty percent of people choose um the
other option
so they're a bunch of people essentially
choose the three thousand dollars for
sure
in problem three at the same time they
choose their minus four thousand with an
eighty percent chance when not when when
given uh problem three prime
so that means essentially we have two
choices here one choice says people are
risk-averse the other choice says people
are risk-loving
in expected utility terms or world this
cannot happen
the reason being that we have one
parameter which is gamma gamma tells us
how risk-averse or how risk-loving or
whether the universe neutral are like
that parameter tells us everything about
your wrist preferences
for all choices that i'm giving you it
cannot be that you're simultaneously
risk-loving and risk-averse
so this evidence essentially sort of
rejecting uh
the expected utility model or cannot
explain this behavior
does this make sense
i sort of wrote this down here but i
think i said everything that's
to be set
any questions on this
so then um so where we're going to go is
essentially a
this people seem to be behaving
differently for gains versus losses
and in addition to that so not only do
people seem to dislike
losses we'll show you some evidence of
that but in addition people seem to be
risk loving for losses
and risk averse for gains and that's
kind of what what kind of manufactures
you are claiming and once you make that
claim
you'll be able to uh explain this uh
these patterns in the data
now a second thing that they show is um
the following they show a problem 11 and
problem 12. i'll let you read
these and uh for yourself um
and essentially you see that 84 so the
choice here is
uh starting in addition to whatever you
have
for sure you're going to be given a
thousand dollars or shekels i guess
um you are now asked to choose between a
thousand with a 50
chance and 500 for sure okay
84 say option b problem two is in
addition to whatever your own
you have been given two thousand uh you
are now asked to choose between
option c which is minus thousand with uh
fifty percent chance
and option d which is minus five hundred
and sixty nine percent uh of people here
say
um they choose option c
okay so what's the problem with this
yes
based on how the question is exactly so
framing matters
uh or reference to points matter and so
what assumption of the expected utility
model is that rejecting
exactly so we we uh um we postulated
that only final outcomes matter
uh uh here um if you write this down it
turns out
option a and option c are exactly the
same in terms of like final
outcomes turns out option b and d are
also exactly the same i'll let you look
at this for a second
so a and c are the same in terms of the
final outcomes b
and c are sorry b and d are also exactly
the same in terms of final outcomes
so that means essentially when you
compare a versus b and c
versus d if you only cared about final
outcomes
you cannot choose different things here
in this
lottery it cannot be that your utility
is defined over just final outcomes
because you just told me you like two
different things for the exact same
thing
right and there's 84 or choose option b
well 69 percent
choose option c so there's a bunch of
people who essentially switch
is that clear
okay so now um uh what is that sort of
what's going on here
well where we're gonna go is like well
it seems like so exactly as you say
framing matters how you frame the
problem matters but why does it matter
well it's because we're setting like a
reference point in the first place
and the first example the reference
point is like a thousand
and there is like a gain relative to a
thousand we look at like people evaluate
this gamble as like
gains in the second example the
references point is set to like 2 000
and now people essentially evaluate this
gamble as losses relative to the 2000.
so that depending on how people think
about gains versus losses
it turns out then people make different
uh choices we'll i'll
be more formal about this but that's
essentially the idea of like why can
conneman and first key their prospect
theory what they
uh propose why can that explain these
behaviors
as opposed to expected utility
okay so now what are sort of the most
important points uh there's uh three of
them i'm going to show you two and then
get to the third one um
at the end so one is like what matters a
lot uh
for people's behaviors is changes rather
than levels
so what they argue is utility is not
defined by people's final states how
much
how much do they end up with but as
opposed to like how much does
um uh changes relative to some reference
point
that could be changes relative to like a
status quo how much do i have right now
and how much does it change positively
or negatively
or it could be relative to some
expectation or some other reference
point
what i showed you here in this example
is like this is not the status quo that
people evaluate
their utility against because the
outcome is always the same
the reference point here is kind of like
the expectation i set you and say okay
here's a thousand and now uh what seems
to be happening is that people's
expectations in fact
become a thousand and then relative to
that expectation people are going to
evaluate gains and losses
um um and similarly if i give you like
say you get a
2 000 again people evaluate the utility
uh
or their their the outcomes uh as gains
and losses
relative to that second there seems to
be loss aversion
people um losses loom larger than gains
that is to say people dislike a loss
that's as large as a gain
by a lot more than they like the game
okay so it's like people if you say you
lose a hundred versus you gain a hundred
people really dislike losing a hundred a
lot more than they
like gaining a a hundred and once you
sort of postulate that but then i can
explain why you reject a bunch of
gambles
because if say like if a gamble is like
minus 10 with 50
chance and uh plus 11 with 50 chance
well you know if you dislike the losses
a lot more if you dislike losing ten
dollars a lot more than
uh uh gaining ten or eleven dollars well
then you're going to like to
reject this um gamble even if the
expected uh value is
is a a positive okay
well we'll write down sort of like
utility function next time that sort of
uh
does this more formally but essentially
those are the two two key ideas there's
a third one which i'm going to get to in
a second
now the key part here is like there is
essentially reference dependence people
evaluate
their outcomes relative to some
reference point
what kinds of examples do we actually
have a reference point when you look on
the world and
again that's kind of very much what i'd
like you to do when you think about
things that you see in the world
what kinds of examples do we have that
people care about reference points
as opposed to final outcomes
yeah uh so my first thought was
you know how we have to pay like 10
cents for shopping
where i was from um ago
so if you use like a musical bag and got
five cents back
that was like not um effective
because like okay five cents back but
like they started charging
right
so exactly when you think about pricing
of different options it matters a lot to
people
it seems that when you uh add five cents
which is subtract five cents or ten
cents or whatever
uh the same changes about like it's just
it's five thin that's at the end of the
day that you have to pay more
uh uh or or less depending on whether
you use a back your choice of using a
back versus not should not be affected
by
uh whether it's framed or or put as like
a loss versus a gain or like a you know
whatever rebate or whatever that you
might get and i think that's true for
many different
that's for true for shopping uh uh
plastic bags like or any other shopping
bags
um but it's also true for many other
options it depends a lot whether you
sort of add on that option
or whether you get sort of essentially
subtracted the option uh as sort of some
discount
yes um
right i think some of it is not exactly
i think there's some
legal constraints to that specific
behavior because
kind of you're not supposed to sort of
trick people but surely some of that is
going on
people love discounts like they love
making good deals
they love sort of getting things cheaper
and there is ways compared to some
reference point
and the reference point since it's hard
to tell what actually should the price
be
is often like the previous price or
something that seems really expensive
and now they're getting it for less
money
and sort of if you get it for half the
price even if it's still quite expensive
you think like you saved half of the
price uh
uh somehow yeah how do you feel about
what you have
they depend on what you see right
so reference points could not just be uh
prices or like uh sort of things that
like affect yourself in certain ways and
then price is the
key example overall the reference point
could just be your environment your
social environment we kind of talk about
this
someday we also may talk about social
preferences kind of people care a lot
about what others do
and their reference point might very
much be formed by what their neighbors
do like how big is the house how big is
their car
uh do they have a swimming pool or not
it could be also like your neighbors
like how good are they at school
how smart are they and so on how good
looking and so on and so forth
so when people evaluate certain outcomes
they often don't evaluate
the levels but rather kind of how much
another person
makes or whatever other people's
outcomes are and part of the reason
might be that like evaluating absolute
outcomes is really hard it's very hard
to actually understand it's
ten thousand dollars fifty thousand
dollars hundred thousand dollars a
million how much money do you actually
need
to be to be happy or that that you like
or how much
what kinds of outcomes are you excited
about and so on
but it's much easier to say you have
something and another person does not or
the other way around it's much easier to
compare with others
it's very hard to actually evaluate
absolute outcomes because who knows you
know what the apps like how how you
should feel about
um that much easier to say i have this
they don't or the other way around
yeah um people sometimes don't want to
let go of um
because they don't want to like see that
they um
right so that's uh exactly that's called
what people call the disposition effect
uh there's actually pretty large
literature uh studying this and lots of
debates on whether it's really going on
or not how important is and so on and so
forth
um but sort of one very basic stylized
fact is like when people
are looking at stocks that they might uh
want to sell
they are much more likely to sell
winners compared to losers
now why is that bad or like well should
you not do that or
right there's a bit of a question kind
of is there like momentum or reversal or
the like
but if you believe in efficient markets
which you know many economists do
or at least some of them who are in
chicago
so if you believe in efficient markets
then
the current stock price should
essentially um
not be or like the previous losses and
so on should not be informative of
what's going on in the future
so in expectations your losers and your
winners if there's any information
about the future about the future
evaluation that should already be
incorporated
in the price so if you look at two
stocks one lost some money one gain some
money
uh they're equally likely to to to to
make you money
um and so if anything what they show in
the these papers is like there's
momentum
this is what you're saying is that the
winners actually are in fact
going to be more likely to to increase
value compared to the losers
but people tend to essentially um
want to sort of realize gains people
seem to be happy about making gains
they seem to be very reluctant to uh
sell
the losers and there's some questions on
like how costly is that actually
but that's a very robust pattern in the
data
the same is also true i'm going to show
you um on monday the same is also true
for houses
people are much less likely to sell
their house
when it has lost value compared to when
it gained value
and you know controlling for a bunch of
things yeah
yeah so that's a little tricky there
might be other things going on but
exactly
it could just be that like if you don't
go to a movie
um when you have bought a ticket
yourself it's sort of perceived as a
loss and you really don't like that
it's a little complicated how to think
about this in simple terms because in
some sense the loss is
still there um but anyway yeah exactly
it's like you sort of lost money it's
almost like as if you lost the movie
ticket
and then get that sort of some value uh
from it there's a bit of a question
whether you sort of integrate these two
things or not
because people think about monetary
terms versus other things often in
separation
but i think some of that is exactly
people feel like uh they have a loss
if they uh don't take advantage of their
movie tickets so i'm going to show you
some examples that actually much more
basic in some ways when you think about
like visual illusions
this is called like the size contrast
illusion so one of those things is like
when you look at circles or things
that's supposed to look the same
that in fact are the same size they look
quite different depending on what you
contrast things with things look quite
different for example if you look at
these circles that are in the middle
they're in fact exactly the same size
but in fact they don't really look like
that
similarly if you look at these two
circles it's perhaps more stark these
circles are in fact
exactly the same size that are in the
middle every time i'm teaching this
class i'm sort of like have to convince
myself that they are actually the same
size so i kind of like
print it out and sort of measure and to
make sure that it's actually the same
size and they are i checked
but it's very when you see this even if
you know it's an illusion it's very hard
to convince yourself that it's not
um but they are the same size um when
you look at these bars when you look at
the upper black bar and the lower black
bar again
it seems like somehow the upper one is
like wider but in fact it's not and
again it's
about the contrast to to the other side
there's this one which throws me off the
most there's like when you look at
fields a and b they are the same color
that's
hard to believe once you see it they are
actually the same color and again i
would print it out and actually put them
next to each other they are
the exact same color i checked uh
there's also a video that you can watch
that sort of shows this
um uh and exactly what's what's
happening is the way we perceive colors
is coming from
a contrast right so like black does not
or gray does not look as gray when
a white or darker gray is next to it
this is um similarly here if you look at
the the gray of this bar
this is the exact same gray again you
can print it out and sort of look at it
it's the exact same when you look at it
it just does look like on the right side
it's darker than on the left
now there's plenty of examples of
reference dependence for vision
there's tons of them they're kind of
quite interesting
at some level it tells us something
about the brain like in some ways we can
learn about like essentially the way we
um evaluate certain outcomes overall is
essentially
it's much easier for us or we think
about in contrast it's very hard for us
often to think about
levels but of course that's vision so
like in some sense what do we learned
really about utility
um one thing you can look at is um
uh bronze and silver medal winners at
the olympics presumably or arguably
winning a civil
silver medal is sort of better than a
bronze medal winner if you look at these
two um uh women one of them won the
silver medal um
one of them won bronze so what people
have done and psychologists have done is
like took actually a bunch of pictures
from like ceremonies uh of bronze and
silver winners and just looked at like
who looks happier
and when you do that um essentially um
uh the bronze medalists look on average
happier than the silver medalist
presumably it's because you know they
just missed gold while the other person
uh sort of one bronze because you know
it's great to be third as opposed to uh
fourth
um and there's more uh you can read more
about this but but that's sort of like
one uh
uh finding now
it's true for lots of different
feelings perceptions judgment and so on
people compare stimuli in various ways
when it comes to temperature when it
comes to all sorts of things
relative to reference levels it's very
hard for them to evaluate
it in absolute terms so it's easy to say
you know when you look at like water
it's very hard to say what's the
temperature even if you sort of practice
this a lot
it's very easy to say one bucket of
water is warmer than another it's very
hard to sort of say it's like
70 degrees or 60 or whatever it's very
hard to sort of understand what absolute
temperatures are
and i think that's the same in some ways
for a lot of
a lot of consumption or other decisions
it's very hard to say how much would you
pay for this or
how happy should i be with certain
outcomes because people need some
reference and often than the reference
of either some expectations or their
neighbors or
just comparing between different options
so you know that's the example i
mentioned previously which is you know
it's much easier to compare your income
or any outcomes your grades etc compared
to what your friend has
it's much harder to say how much an
extra a thousand dollars or having like
fifty thousand dollars per year
is that good or bad uh it depends a lot
um uh
what do you compare it um uh against um
so what people tend to do and this is
exactly what kahneman and tversky were
postulating is that people compare the
outcomes relative to
reference points so um and again we're
going to write this down
in more detail at the beginning of next
class
but what kind of man and swarsky were
postulating were essentially two things
uh they're postulating a there's a
reference level of consumption or any
outcomes
we're going to talk a little bit about
like what actually is this reference
level where it's coming from first for
now we just assume
there's a reference level that people
consume uh compare the outcomes against
and then there is um against that
outcomes are
are compared and in particular um uh
the function is like steeper on the left
compared to the right
right essentially um losses are loom
larger than gains
so like going uh a down by a 10 units on
the left or one unit on the left is more
painful than
uh you know going up on the right
relative to that reference
points okay and so that's uh
we all said you know so then you know
what evidence or experimental evidence
uh do we in fact um have for that
so one um example so we have sort of
experimental evidence of this and i'm
going to show you next time a bunch of
different examples
of like real world choices uh starting
uh from golfing to selling houses to
lots of other outcomes
but sort of the experimental evidence
that the earlier experimental evidence
that people showed were
uh preferences oversea gambles i showed
you some of those already
and then in particular unwillingness to
trade different options
uh uh compared to like an alternative
option that i shoot that's what people
refer to as the
endowment effect so let me show you
first the gambles we already have that
in some sense these are like essentially
gambles people seem really really
risk-averse
when they when when they are offered
these gambles
conneman and versky would say people are
essentially loss of verse people really
dislike
the loss of ten dollars relative to the
gain of eleven dollars and we can
explain that behavior and that's a very
robust finding that people decline these
kinds of types of gambles
convenient first you would say uh that's
evidence of loss aversion
now you might say these are really small
gambles really do we really care about
them
well once you do this like with 500 550
or whatever larger amounts people also
do the same
it's hard to do this with like real
world money because it's quite a bit of
money
and turns out there's actually some
studies who do that as well they did
this like for real um with mba students
financial analysts and rich investors
and even those uh people like uh uh tend
to then
um turn down those kinds of gambles so
there seems to be quite of evidence of
lots of version when
people are um uh given the choices
between gains and losses people seem to
really dislike
losses now what's the endowment effect
that's sort of the
the perhaps most famous um evidence
uh in this domain is essentially is
people
when are endowed with a certain item
they really do not like to trade
and so the way you would do that is um
you uh an experiment we give people an
item and then you ask them essentially
and it's a randomly
uh a random selected fraction of people
are
given an item and then either people are
offered the choice
would you either keep your item or would
you get another item that's sort of the
same value overall
or what people do is like they have some
experiments there's many of these
experiments
uh you you you give some people one item
and some other people another item and
then see would you like to trade
with each other and what you see
essentially very people are extremely
reluctant
to trade there's many of these kinds of
examples
like for example um
yeah so one example is sorry i skipped
that which is one example is like if you
just give people an item
usually it's like a mug if you give
people a mug and ask like
how much uh do i have to pay you to give
me uh to
to sell me this mug okay people say
large amounts they would say like five
dollars
if instead you ask them here's a mug
would you like to purchase this mug
instead of controlling for
um uh how much money they have and so on
if you ask them like would you like to
buy this mug people would say like two
dollars or something
it's the same mug and you know
essentially their choice depends on
whether you give them the mug versus uh
whether you endow them with
the mag which is where the endowment
effect name comes from or whether you
just sort of like ask their willingness
to pay when they don't have it
there's tons of different experiments
that uh do exactly that
now a different version of that is like
so this one is about like
uh buying a mug with selling a mug
buying and selling prices
different versions of that is to say uh
you have like a population of students
or different people
and what you do is essentially you find
two items that on average have the same
valuation
right and knitch was doing that and um
so he had like mugs and pens and he sort
of calibrated such that on average
people when you just ask people people's
willingness to pay for these mugs and
pens are like on average roughly the
same of course there's variation
but on average it's the same and then
you offered half the students mugs and
half the students pens
and then offered an exchange he also
offered an exchange for
an addition of five cents and saying
like okay maybe you're just exactly
indifferent so i'm giving you five cents
in case you exchange
and it turns out that the mug people
like to keep their mugs and the pen
people like to keep their pens uh
and ninety percent of people uh do that
that's one of the most robust findings
in in experimental economics
uh there are some questions on like
expectations do people expect to keep
the mugs and so on and so there's some
complications for that
but the basic result is very robust and
has been shown in many different
settings any questions on this
okay so what's going on here well
essentially
the reference point seems to be
essentially affected by
ownership so if you own a mug your
reference point is owning a mug
so now if i ask you would you like me to
sell me this mug well now you have a
loss of a mug
so essentially you're in the last domain
of mugs so i have to pay you more money
to compensate you for that
if in contrast you do not own a mug so
like you have zero mugs your reference
point is
zero mugs i'm asking you like would you
like to receive a mug
or like buy a mug from me then
essentially on the gain domain
um and sort of what i showed you here
previously
one second so when i'm asking you to
purchase your mug essentially you're on
the left side of this uh
figure you're on the last domain your
marginal utility of mugs is very high
i have to pay you a lot of money to
receive the mug from you
in contrast if you have zero mugs i'm
asking you would you like to purchase a
mug you're on the right side of those
reference points
so essentially now you're in the gain
domain and now if i
you're not willing to pay a lot of money
uh because um
uh you're gaining a mug on top of that
you're also going to gain loss of domain
of money but like i'm setting that sort
of like
aside does that make any sense sir
so
right and so people uh hate losses more
than they like to gain so they stick
with the mug and similarly that's the
same thing for the
pen owners there's lots of different
examples
of those kinds of um uh behaviors for
example
law school students were asked to assess
compensation for pain and uh
suffering damages in one study uh this
is
expected to last or listen in this
example as expected to last three years
and be quite unpleasant uh there's no
earnings impact on earnings capacity
for example it would be extreme
stiffness in the upper back and neck
i think that would probably affect your
earnings capacity but but anyway
let's assume that's not um the case um
so then some students are let you
imagine they're were being injured
how much would you be um uh willing to
pay to
get better okay so your reference point
is like you're injured
how much are you willing to pay um to
get better
and people said 151 448
on average now another group of students
was led in this randomized has led to
imagine being
uninjured like how much are you willing
to pay
would i need to pay you to accept the
injury right you're not um
injured now i'm asking you like how much
are you willing to pay um or how much
you have to pay you how much you have to
compensate you
to accept this injury now you would
extinct this is like the same thing
because you know uh you
but what's your price of not being
injured uh the price of health should be
independent on like which way i'm asking
you
turns out when people are um have their
good health
they're willing to pay a lot more uh uh
uh to keep it or to not lose
it compared to like when they have lost
it um when they regain it
um there's another um uh quite nice
example i'm showing you um
uh uh here one second so that was um in
case you didn't see that was uh dinar
daeneryelli
who has a other nasa or several nice
books one of them is predictably
irrational which is a quite nice
uh uh read um so there's lots of these
kinds of examples of
um loss loss aversion or what's called
the endowment effect when people have
staff
essentially um they're not willing to
part it when they don't have it they're
willing to pay
less um one nice thing that ariel was
also talking about a little bit about
how people then explain these kinds of
behaviors
we're going to get back to that and i
think lecture 20 or something which is
about kind of like
i think what's going on here is very
obvious potentially people are loss of
verse and they're randomized until they
gain the losses and that's kind of what
explaining their behavior
but people don't necessarily understand
that they're being randomized in one or
the other condition
and they then sort of try to explain
their behavior in various ways and
saying i want to tell my grandchildren
about this
but in some sense they're sort of like
rationalizing their preferences and they
don't necessarily sort of understand
with these stories
and they don't necessarily understand
where these preferences are coming from
even though we kind of know because the
person has been like manipulated into
those kinds of uh choices we'll get back
to that
now the third part of um kaimantversky's
prospect theory of their paper is
essentially what's called diminishing uh
sensitivity
i'm going to get back to this and sort
of write this down in more detail
on monday but essentially it's like
people are risk averse
in the gain domain but risk loving and
the last uh region what does this look
like
essentially um the utility function is a
little bit different
from what i showed you before it's not
only like more steep on the left
relative to the reference point compared
to the right
but it's also uh concave on the right
and convex on the
left okay and what that gets you and
what that buys you essentially is that
people are uh risk-averse in the in the
in the game domain but people are uh
risk-loving in the
lost domain and that sort of is needed
to be able to explain some of the
behaviors that i showed you
uh early on in the conomonsky evidence
so again i'll i'll tell you about these
um this in more detail and sort of write
this down
more precisely and then we're going to
talk about like many different
applications
in particular sort of there's the
endowment effect which is kind of what i
talked to already about before
there's labor supply employment and
effort depending what people expect how
much they earn
they they make different choices about
how many
hours they actually work depending on
the expectation whether it's above or
below a reference point
people are reluctant to sell their
houses if they're at a loss compared to
again
even for very similar houses and
marathon running people are
trying to reach essentially certain uh
targets people like to be [ __ ]
below four hours or three hours and the
like um there's the disposition effect
that you mentioned which essentially is
people like to sell um uh winners
compared to
to to losers and these insurance choice
that i already showed you before
there's some evidence on uh
violence in the household the particular
example is about
football or games essentially i think
football games
were essentially depending on whether
people expected a loss or win
of their team and when they actually
lost a a a
loss or win of the team that actually
happens there's more violence when there
are unexpected losses compared to
expected losses which has been
consistent with um loss aversion
um what's next so next we're going to
talk about many applications of
reference dependence
on monday uh i'd like you to sort of
read the the kind of manchester um
paper at least the first pages sort of
to get some sense of their work
and then on wednesday we're going to
start talking about social preferences
in particular we're going to have some
experiments in class there's going to be
no no readings for that there's the
opportunity to make money
in class at least some of it